[Musik]
[Gelächter]
guten tag manchmal ist eine nützliche
illusion besser als eine nutzlose
wahrheit davon jedenfalls ist unser
heutiger gast überzeugt kein wunder
schließlich ist colson whitehead
schriftsteller gerade in den vergangenen
jahren hat der weltweit erfolgreiche
romane zur geschichte amerikas verfasst
die menschen in finsteren scheinbar
ausweglosen situationen schildern und
die dennoch die hoffnung nicht aufgeben
ihren weg ins freie zu finden deshalb
ist ausgerechnet fiktionen sind die uns
als menschen wahrhaft befreien oder auch
fast larven können wir werden es in der
kommenden stunde hoffentlich
herausfinden zunächst aber einmal
herzlich willkommen
danke für die einladung erweitert gerade
die letzten fünf jahre ihres schaffens
hatten ja etwas wirklich unwirkliches an
sich sie haben in zwei aufeinander
folgenden büchern den pulitzerpreis
gewonnen den national book award sie
waren auf dem cover des time -magazins
wenn sie als schriftsteller diesen
letzten fünf jahren einen titel geben
sollten um eine geschichte zu schreiben
wie würde denn ihr titel lautet
vielleicht dem dunkeln a
als underground railroad erschien und
sich gut verkaufte wurde drei monate
später trotz gewählt dann kam de negri
bois raus und verkauften sich gut und
das corona virus tauchte auf vor einem
monat kam mein neuestes buch raus mal
sehen was diesmal geschieht wohl nichts
gutes also gibt es eine art unwucht
zwischen dem persönlichen erfolg den sie
hatten und der entwicklung ihres landes
in eben diesen jahren
ja jemand muss wohl die zeche dafür
bezahlen
im universum herrscht ein gleichgewicht
wenn mir etwas gutes widerfährt müssen
offenbar alle anderen darunter leiden es
gibt ja eine geschichte einen titel den
man ihn schon gegeben hat nämlich auf
dem cover des time magazins das lautet
amerikas storyteller der
geschichtenerzähler amerikas ist das ein
titel mit dem sie sich identifizieren
können märz im ziel also ich habe ein
paar t-shirts mit dem aufdruck amerikas
geschichten als machen lassen die trage
ich jeden tag auf dem weg zur arbeit ich
bin einfach jemand der seine albernen
geschichten erzählt und darauf hofft
dass ihr nicht komplett falsch liegt mit
seinen ideen umso besser wenn sich die
leute davon angesprochen fühlen falls
nicht was auch schon der fall war
schreibe ich halt einfach das nächste
buch
ein solcher titel bedeuten ich bin ein
ganz normaler typ der sich hinsetzt und
sich mühe gibt die nächste idee nicht zu
verpassen
unter spielen oder überspielen das
natürlich jetzt ein bisschen ironisch
aber das ist ja tatsächlich nicht nur so
dass sie in den letzten jahren zu
amerikas storyteller geworden sind
sondern auch eine spezifische rolle und
eine spezifische erfahrung bedienen
mussten nämlich auch der geschichten
erzähler des schwarzen amerikas des
afroamerikanischen amerikas und da kann
man ja sagen dass es eine rolle die so
übermäßig ist eine ganze historische
erfahrung zu verkörpern dass man sie
eigentlich nur bewusst ablehnen kann
ich sehe das nicht so als habe es nie so
empfunden vor underground railroad habe
ich ein buch über eine poker turnier
serie geschrieben und davor die sahen
die apokalypse in new york was andere
von dem was ich mache erhalten spielt
dabei keine rolle
wenn ich für ein schwarzes amerika
spreche in meinem buch da nur für mein
schwarzes amerika
es gibt in den usa 30 millionen von uns
und niemand kann anspruch darauf erheben
für die ganze community zu sprechen ich
mache mein eigenes ding
wenn sich andere davon angesprochen
fühlen ist das toll manchmal passiert
das manchmal nicht
aber ist es denn wirklich so dass die
erfahrung nur jeweils individuell ist
oder gibt es nicht auch eine art
geteilten erfahrungs kern der ist dann
auch möglich oder sogar nötig werden
lässt für eine ganze community zu
sprechen
es geht nicht darum für etwas zu
sprechen damit ein kunstwerk
funktioniert muss es etwas ansprechen
mit dem sich jeder identifizieren kann
egal ob man in den usa lebt schwarz ist
oder die sklaverei auf wenn eine figur
die individuelle erfahrung zu einer
universellen bedeutung transzendiert
wenn sich deren charakter oder
geschichten auf etwas größeres beziehen
kann sich jeder darin erkennen
ich kann mich in ruh mehr hinein
versetzen obwohl ich kein griechischer
soldat oder soldatin irgendwelcher art
er hat etwas thematisiert dass die
menschen über tausende von jahren
angesprochen
liebe es wie seine themen sind
universell und werden durch seine
soldaten und ups kriegsgeschichten
verkörpert
nochmals ich spreche für keine gruppe
ich transportiere einfach die wirren
ideen
das ist ja fast schon eine kleine
philosophie des erzählens man nimmt
einen individuellen fall oder ein klar
lokalisiertes ereignis aber strebt dann
an dort etwas zu erzählen was diesen
kontext transzendiert sie sprach selbst
davon dass eigentlich eine
universalistische dimension hat würden
sie so auch ihre idee von literatur
beschreiben
ich versuche einfach meine künstlerische
bestimmung zu legen in einer art vater
gelingt dies fühlen sich die leute an
mich freut dass ich durch die letzten
jahre und bücher gelernt habe gut
geformte figuren zu schaffen die über
die ursprüngliche geschichte
hinausweisen
mein erstes buch handelte von einer
fahrstuhl inspektoren die frühen bücher
waren recht kopflastig und abgehoben
habe eine sehr persönliche
autobiografische erzählung über das
heranwachsen in den 80er jahren
genau war wichtig für meine entwicklung
als person und als schriftsteller nicht
so abgehoben zu sein mich stärker einzug
seitdem wurden meine figuren erkennbarer
und abgerundete
also haben sie das gefühl sie sind
einfach ein besserer handwerker geworden
wenn man etwas 20 jahre lang macht wird
man hoffentlich besser das gilt auch für
ein lehrer oder eine herzchirurgen die
mit der erfahrung von 20 jahren wohl
weniger patienten umbringen wird
ich stelle mir das in etwa so vor dass
man sich bemüht besser wird irgendwann
mal ein plateau erreicht und von da an
geht es dann abwärts sie läuft es bei
den meisten dingen leben ich denke ich
bin immer noch am lärm als mensch und
als schriftsteller
aber es gibt ja schon ein unterschied
man wird möglicherweise persönlich immer
besser aber das muss nicht unbedingt mit
erfolg korrelieren und bei ihnen war es
hier so dass es nicht nur eine offenbare
qualitätszuwachs cup sondern es gab auch
eine explosionsartige entwicklung was
ihren erfolg angeht und sie haben das
einmal beantwortet in bezug auf die
zumutungen die mit die damit einhergehen
die erwartungen anderer menschen sind
genau dass die erwartungen anderer
menschen das klingt unheimlich cool es
klingt aber auch sehr illusorisch
qualität guter erfolg sind zwei
unterschiedliche dinge nicht alle
großartigen bücher sind erfolgreich ich
halte mein buch und broker für eines
meiner besten bücher obwohl niemand es
wirklich mochte
das ist auch das einzige buch das bisher
nicht auf deutsch übersetzt wurde
übrigens
sehen sie aber
es war wichtig für meine entwicklung als
schriftsteller und führte
es ist ein teil meines lebens
dass andere sich nicht damit
identifizieren und ist kein
kommerzieller erfolg war bedeutet nicht
dass es künstlerisch misslungen ist das
sind unterschiedliche dinge
nun kann man aber auch sagen dass in den
letzten jahren ihres schaffens auch eine
art themenwechsel stattgefunden hat das
waren sie haben bücher über zombies
geschrieben über poker über eine
kindheit die letzten zwei oder drei
bücher insbesondere underground railroad
und die nickel boys waren aber auch über
eine spezifische traumatische periode
der amerikanischen geschichte aus einer
afro-amerikanischen perspektive aus
einer perspektive der unterdrückung das
kam kann man sagen relativ spät in ihrer
autoren biografie was hat diesen wechsel
bewirkt
die idee zur underground railroad
entstand im jahr 2000
ich war damals aber noch nicht soweit
ein blick über die sklaverei zu
schreiben also schob ich es auch
aber auch meine frühen bücher die
fahrstuhl inspektoren und john henry
days greifen auf ihre art die themen
geschichte und rasse auf
ich denke das thema dass sklaverei
direkt anzugehen ohne den rückgriff auf
die postmoderne
erforderte eine neue herangehensweise
die auch meiner künstlerischen
entwicklung vor fünf jahren entsprach
das zweite buch zur us geschichte die
nickel gold handelt von dem jim crow
gesetzen und der rassentrennung in
amerika
die zwei hauptfiguren landen als
teenager in einer fürchtet ahlen
besserungsanstalt
ohne die arbeit an den figuren in der
letzte sommer auf long island und selbst
im poker buch wäre die darstellung der
beiden jugendlichen nie so lebendig
traum
für mich ist das also weniger ein
themenwechsel als vielmehr eine
verfeinerung ein weiterer schritt auf
dem weg den ich vor 30 jahren
eingeschlagen hatte was ich meine
eigenen spider man comics
man beginnt man fehler und lernt daraus
und so sterben hoffentlich weniger
patienten auf dem operationstisch
patience and able
also auch das gefühl dass man gewisse
themen vielleicht erst später in seinem
eigenen werden anpackt weil sie so
schwer und so komplex sind dass man noch
nicht bereit für sie gewesen wäre früher
ich hatte schlicht angst ich hielt mich
nicht für gut genug als schriftsteller
um das thema der sklaverei mit der
erforderlichen ernsthaftigkeit anzugehen
ich war als personen nicht reich genug
figuren zu erschaffen welche die
geschichte der sklaverei verkörpern
konnten also wartet
wie tragfähig ein bunt projekt ist
erweist sich dann im laufe der zeit wie
schrieb ein buch und stellte mir die
frage ob ich bereit war
bis 2014 war die antwort immer nein ich
hatte es offensichtlich 14 jahre lang
vor mir hergeschoben auch wenn es wie
aus dem selbsthilfebuch klingt ich bin
dem was ich hätte tun sollen ausgewichen
und das war
eines ihrer bücher den nickel boys
beginnt wenn ich es richtig sehe im jahr
1963 dass es eine art schlüssel ja auch
in der amerikanischen geschichte für die
bürgerrechtsbewegung wir haben ein
ausschnitt aus diesem jahr 263 von einem
kollegen von ihnen james baldwin eine
ikonische gestalt der amerikanischen
literatur und er hat dort einige sehr
harte auch sehr drastische dinge zu
sagen sehen wir uns das mal kurz an
ihr personal
post ist ein pulli liegend war
und was kann
ich wünsche euch bei uns kann jay
ist bisher ist breit und spielarten
kannte er
die sind alle anbieter
sie sind alle
in
der holz
und
überlässt
das gerade erst neu
ordnen
man sieht einen erschöpften fast
verzweifelten james ball drin und das
ist jetzt 45 jahre her in wie weit
würden sie sagen aus ihrer frauen hat
sich die natur dieser frage geändert
oder auch gar nicht geändert
nicht wirklich vieles von dem was er
anspricht trägt die lebensweise in den
usa immer noch
man wartete damals auf die einführung
der wichtigsten bürgerrechtsgesetz für
die man 15 jahre lang auf der straße
gekämpft hatte
1965 kam dann das war recht gesetz und
dann werden sie geboren das betrifft ja
dann praktisch auch ihr biografisches
werden genau diese phase
nun als heranwachsender in den 70er
jahren sah ich die umsetzung der
bürgerrechte
als selbstverständliche zeichen des
erzielten fortschritt es gehört zum
erwachsenwerden festzustellen dass nicht
alles was man in der schule lernt auch
stimmt
der protagonist in den little boy
vertraut darauf dass amerika sich
wandelt und er teil einer generation ist
die den wandel fordert bleibt
als ihn die realität in form der jim
crow gesetze einholt gerät sein leben
aus den fugen und er merkt dass amerika
sich nicht verändern will
vor zwölf jahren hörte man oft die
gesellschaft hätte ihren rassismus
überwunden das ist um es geräte kein
schwarzer würde ernsthaft von einer post
rassistischen gesellschaft sprechen
dutzende von millionen rassisten in den
usa verschwinden nicht einfach nur weil
ein schwarzer zum präsident gewählt wird
ihre ignoranz lebt fort in erwartung von
jemandem
es gibt immer noch viel zu viele von
ihnen für eine funktionierende
gesellschaft
so würden sie sagen diese ganze rede von
einem hostel amerika es ist eigentlich
eine
erstellende fiktionale rede die nichts
mit den tatsächlichen gegebenheiten sind
zu tun hat
ja an der wahl von tom verstummte das
gerede über die post rassistische
gesellschaft das zeigt wie nutzlos der
begriff ist
sie schreiben ja nun über die geschichte
auch dass sklaverei aber nicht in einer
form die jetzt rein documenta tief wäre
in ihrem werk underground railroad dass
eine art untergründige eisenbahnnetz
imaginiert mit dem die sklaven im
achtzehnten und neunzehnten jahrhundert
aus dem süden in den norden fliegen das
underground railroad war wohl eine
metapher für ein netzwerk das existiert
aber es war keine railroad sondern das
war ein netzwerk von helfern und sie
haben diese metapher genommen und haben
einfach die eisenbahn wirklich erfunden
ist das eine idee dass die literatur zur
fantastic greift wenn die realität
keinen ausweg mehr bietet
nun die mittel richten sich nach der
jeweiligen aufgabe manchmal braucht es
den realismus wie bei den nickelpreis
manchmal die fantasie mit
einer geradlinigen erzählung über die
flucht eines sklaven in den norden hätte
ich mich nicht auf diese weise mit der
geschichte auseinandersetzen
die protagonistin steigt in die
eisenbahn und reicht in verschiedene
staaten
jedes kapitels ein staat in diesem buch
muss man sagen also im prinzip wird
seine am preise durch amerika als flucht
einer person
es gibt den staat sich der schwarzen
utopie der weißen vorherrschaft der
paternalistischen regierung das
funktioniert nicht in einem
realistischen roman deshalb das konzept
als fantastische roman mit all den
herausforderungen und stärken die damit
einhergehen
der letzte satz dieses buches den würde
ich gerne einmal vorlesen weil der
lautet folgendermaßen sie
fragte sich sie ist die heldin cora von
wo er geflohen war wie schlimm es dort
war und wie weit erfahren musste ehe er
es hinter sich ließ
das ist ja ein ende der den das den
gedanken nahe legt dass es dieses hinter
sich lassen diesen ort eigentlich gar
nicht gibt sondern dass dieser ort es
hinter sich lassen es niemals zu finden
wäre
das bringt uns zurück zu dem was james
baldwin ansprach und zur frage wie sich
die welt jahre nach dieser clip
tatsächlich verändert hat
unsere geschichte und unsere namen mit
uns gut haben sie das ende vorgelesen
ich hatte keine ahnung mehr wie der
letzte satz lautete
die frage ist wie weit wir gehen können
und all dem was wir mit uns mit tragen
lasse dass der leserin oder dem leser
man liest verschiedenes in dieses ende
einige sehen darin hoffnung bei anderen
klingt ein offensichtlicher pessimismus
also eine ambivalenz amendt zwischen
einer helleren und einer dunkleren
perspektive auf diese möglichkeiten die
philosophin amerikanisch deutsche
philosophin susan nehmen hat kürzlich
ein buch veröffentlicht das große
resonanz gefunden hat auch in den usa
learning from the germans und in diesem
buch legt sie den gedanken nahe dass die
vergangenheitsaufarbeitung
der deutschen ein beispiel sein könnte
für die vergangenheitsaufarbeitung
der amerikaner in bezug auf ihre eigene
geschichte dass es dort also eine
ähnliche gründlichkeit geben müsse sie
aber bisher noch nicht stattgefunden hat
schön wäre
diesen sommer aber gab es diese wütenden
proteste weiter eltern die verlangten
dass die kinder an den schulen davor
bewahrt werden müssten von der
verstörenden geschichte der sklaverei
der segregation der geschichte unserer
ahnen und unseres landes
niemand will über die enteignung der
native americans oder das erbe der
sklaverei und der segregation sprechen
mit all ihren folgen es wäre sehr
wünschenswert aber ich sehe nicht dass
irgendetwas in der art geschehen wird
solange ich lebe
wir sind hier nun fast dieselbe
generation und in meiner schulzeit war
so dass beispielsweise diese
vergangenheits beschäftigung ganz
intensiv war mehrere jahre des schul
plans dominierte ist das denn ihrer in
erinnerung nach in ihrer schulzeit
ähnlich zentral gewesen oder war das
überhaupt ein wichtiges thema
heute ist es wohl besser in den 70er
jahren hörten wir zehn minuten über die
sklaverei und 40 minuten abram lincoln
der die sklaven befreit
wir hatten zehn minuten über die
rassentrennung die 47 minuten über
martin luther king und die
bürgerrechtsgesetz
der unterricht konzentrierte sich auf
oberflächliche maßnahmen anstatt die
bestehenden realitäten zu beleuchten
es mag heute etwas besser sein aber ich
bin schockiert darüber wie groß der
widerstand immer noch ist
wenn wir die parallele noch weiter
treiben dann gibt es ja auch die frage
der wiedergutmachung der reparationen
und das ist nach wie vor ein thema oder
eine frage ob es in den usa auch
beispielsweise finanzielle reparationen
an afroamerikaner geben sollte ob das
auch eine finanzielle wiedergutmachung
wäre die heute noch nötig scheint wie
stehen sie zu dieser frage
ich bin seit vielen jahren
freiberuflicher schriftsteller
ich betrachte die dinge aus dieser rate
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass die spitze
alt werde und wenn dann sicher nicht
pünktlich also haben sie ja ein eher
entspanntes verhältnis zu diesen fragen
nicht geschehen darüber nachzudenken ist
reine zeitverschwendung
hat das vielleicht auch damit zu tun
dass diese
ausmaß diese erfahrung einfach so
enormes dass es fast unsinnig erscheint
es überhaupt zu adressieren man redet ja
da im 18 19 jahrhundert von 40 millionen
menschen die in fast gelungen den usa
lebten kann es einfach sein dass es zu
enormes und sich dem überhaupt noch zu
wenden zu können
niemand hat wirklich interesse an dieser
frage
und sie sind auch nicht daran
interessiert und hatte das gefühl dass
sie als schriftsteller schon das
bedürfnis haben diese geschichten zu
erzählen diese geschichten ins
bewusstsein zu bringen sie können ja
nicht sagen niemand ist daran
interessiert wenn sie zwei bücher
darüber schreiben die genau um diese
traumatisierungen kreisen
nicht nur 2 aber ich sehe das nicht mit
den reparationszahlungen so wie ich die
menschen kenne da kommt nichts
ein leitthema ihrer bücher wie es
scheint ist ja auch die frage nach der
resilienz einzelner personen
beispielsweise in den nickel bau ist mit
ihrem zweiten buch das jüngst erschienen
ist geht es um zwei jugendliche die eine
reform anstalt
gezwungen werden schreckliche dinge zu
erleiden diese reform anstatt hat eine
lange geschichte von tötungen von
sexuellem missbrauch von gewalt
missbrauch und der eine schafft es im
leben diese traumatisierung wegzustecken
und der andere nicht der eine wurstelt
sich so durch und der andere zerbricht
daran das scheint ja auch bei den
anderen büchern immer so eine frage zu
sein was macht es dass die menschen
einerseits durch kommen und die anderen
es nicht schaffen
in meinem song geht es nicht zu sehr und
sahen dies als um das trauma und das
wieder aufstehen nach persönlichen und
universellen katastrophen dieses thema
zieht sich auch durch andere bücher wie
kann man das grauen überleben wie halten
wir den glauben an ein menschliches
zusammenleben auf recht wo wir heilen
können
cantieni etwas anderes als die plantage
trotzdem glaubt sie an den abstrakten
begriff der freiheit sonst würde sie die
flucht nie unternehmen
wird in den glauben an eine bessere welt
nur sie gibt seinem leben einen sinn
dafür kämpft er ist das nun eine
nützliche illusion oder realität
in meinen anfängen als schriftsteller
musste ich an mein erfolg glauben ich
musste darauf vertrauen ein verleger zu
finden und einen roman von 300 seiten
fertig stellen zu können obwohl sich
niemand wirklich vom entscheiden
interessierte
es war eine nützliche illusion zu
glauben dass ich irgendwann einmal ein
richtiger schriftsteller sein könnte
die welt lehrt uns immer wieder das
scheitern
trotzdem brauchen wir mut und die
hoffnungen auf einen zufluchtsort
das ist ja eine sehr amerikanische man
kann sagen dass es eine grundphilosophie
des landes der philosoph william james
sprach man von dem wild überlief dass
man sich ein ziel setzen wo man noch gar
nicht weiß ob es überhaupt realistisch
ist um es erreichen zu können diese
zukunftshoffnung da gibt es den begriff
der hoffnung einerseits aber an amerika
immer auch den face das hat auch etwas
quasi religiöses die hoffnung auf etwas
anderes vielleicht auf einen gott der
ihm dabei unterstützt
nur nach europäer sind sehr religiös ihr
seid politik es gibt auch hier
verfolgung anhänger
meine großmutter kam 1920 aus barbados
bei alles aller nach amerika in der
hoffnung auf einen besseren ort
ich will damit sagen dass die welt ein
schrecklicher ort ist was gibt diesen
schrecken sind
und der glaube an einen besseren ort für
den wir kämpfen obwohl wir ihn noch nie
gesehen habe
wir wissen nicht wie amerika aussieht
aber wir sind bereit die ozeane zu
überqueren der ursprüngliche
amerikanische traum ist der eines
zufluchtsort
ihre eigene biografie ist jetzt nun eine
recht andere sie sind als sohn von
unternehmensberatern in new york groß
geworden und sie haben in harvard
studiert und haben dann zunächst einen
weg beschritten den viele schriftsteller
zunächst bestreiten nämlich den
journalismus und sie waren insbesondere
fernsehkritiker bei der uefa sie schauen
heute noch gerne viel und intensiv
fernsehen was bedeutet ihnen das
fernsehen denn
nun der fernseher war unser babysitter
ich war teil der generation ex ein
typisches schlüssel kennt du hast deinen
eigenen schlüssel bis nach der schule
auf dich gestellt bis der eltern von der
arbeit nach hause kommen das hieß dann
d'elegance insel sitcoms und unzählige
wiederholungen von max
kindheitserinnerungen ich lese comics
auf dem wohnzimmerboden und im
hintergrund laufen mystery serien
installation oder outer limits
ich habe viel vermissen
heute ist fernsehkritik ein respektabler
beruf in den usa
1992 war der traurigste würdeloses
detail des fonds vor dem sich alle
drückten außer mir
ich dachte wie toll für all diese
traurigen nachmittage und die vielen
wiederholungen der drei mädchen und drei
jungen auch noch bezahlt zu werden
aber so kam ich zum schreiben ich lernte
mit redakteuren zusammen zu arbeiten und
meine texte pünktlich abzuliefern
anders als bei einem college aufsatz
gibt es konsequenzen wenn du den artikel
nicht pünktlich ab liefers kannst du
keine zigaretten kaufen und das war
damals das wichtigste ich lernte mein
eigener chef zu sein und mein tages soll
an wörtern zu erfüllen
diese bedeutung des fernsehens für das
was wir heute literatur nennen die ist
ja in unserer generation besonders stark
wir schauen uns mal einen kleinen
ausschnitt eines kollegen von ihnen an
nämlich david foster wallace auch eine
große ikonische gestalt der
amerikanischen gegenwartsliteratur der
2008 aus eigener hand aus dem leben
schied was hat er dazu zu sagen zur
fernseh sozialisierung im amerika der
80er 90er jahre
meine generation wurde durchs fernsehen
erzogen als ich aufwuchs sah ich im
fernsehen den wichtigsten künstlerischen
schnorchel zum universum
fernsehen ist kommerzielle kunst macht
spaß und fördert sehr wenig vom
konsumenten es wirkt sich aus auf das
was menschen in der kunst suchen es
führt zu geschichten die vielleicht
etwas heftiger sind seltsame
anstrengende
dieses phänomen betrifft so einiges was
heute geschieht und schriftsteller
versuchte zu erfassen
daran ist ja wahnsinnig viele
interessant zunächst einmal der einfluss
des fernsehens auf das was literatur
wird würden sie auch sagen dass ihre art
und weise zu schreiben der fernseh
lastig ist oder zumindest filmisch
überformt
in erster linie durch fernsehfilme und
nicht so sehr durch tv-shows mein song
der roman gründet auf den science
fiction apokalypse filmen der 60er und
70er jahre wie die nacht der lebenden
toten oder planet der affen oder megaman
[Musik]
allem shuffle mein neuester roman kommt
vom heist movies dieser art down low
komödien stützen sich eher auf einen
film narrativ die popkultur aus musik tv
und film hat mich stark beeinflusst es
hat ja auch funktioniert
ich schäme mich nicht dafür
es ist aber auch deswegen interessant
weil solch ein zitat von einem jungen
menschen mittlerweile historisch wirkt
meine teenager kinder gucken kein
fernsehen mehr und ich nehme an die
jungen menschen die sie kennen gucken
auch kein fernsehen mehr das heißt das
ist als medium ja eigentlich schon teil
einer vergangenheit geworden
ja seine aussage stammt aus der zeit vor
dem internet leute starren alle gebannt
auf ihre mobiltelefone und konsumieren
podcast oder social media nein hätte er
spricht ja auch über die auswirkungen
von fernsehen auf ihr
aufmerksamkeitsspanne
die heutigen übel sind da schlimmer
social media internet streaming na ja es
handelt sich ja nicht wirklich um übel
das ist völlig okay es soll jeder selbst
entscheiden wie er seine zeit verbringen
will das leben ist kurz das
ist ja so soll ein verfalls nativ und
vielen schriftstellern die jungen
menschen haben nicht mehr genug
aufmerksamkeit sie wollen nicht mehr die
anstrengung unternehmen fiction richtig
ernsthafte literatur zu lesen weil sie
nur noch 30 sekunden
aufmerksamkeitsspanne haben ist das so
eine kulturkritische impuls den sie auch
manchmal in ihren dunklen stunden
für richtig halten
nun vor 50 jahren nannte man das
fernsehen die idioten kiste mailbox ich
denke gute geschichten werden uns immer
an sie wir werden sie suchen und
ich glaube an die zukunft des
geschriebenen wortes selbst wenn es
nicht zutreffe hätte ich doch keine wahl
ich muss schlicht und einfach schreiben
ich habe sie könnten ja auch was anderes
schreiben wie viel ihre kollegen denn
das ist ja auch noch ein effekt dieses
großen wandels vom fernsehen nämlich zu
den serien zu den digital serien auf den
streaming plattform viele schriftsteller
sagen naja eigentlich sind die romane
mittlerweile die großen serien wie mad
men on the wire --wie downton abbey da
passiert fiktion eigentlich und das buch
ist auch für uns als fiktion autoren gar
nicht mehr das medium in dem wir uns
bestätigen sollten
ich habe das als freischaffender anm ein
anfang gemacht hat so mir das schreiben
an einen roman zu ermöglichen für mich
wäre das höchstens ein nebenjob wie das
unterrichten um eine rechnung bezahlen
und romane schreiben zu können
vor 20 jahren schrieb ich zusammen mit
meinem cousin ein action film drehbuch
das unterrichtete ich damals in es gab
mir zwei jahre lang die möglichkeit an
meinen roma zu arbeiten wir
kontaktierten dann einen agenten der es
als verschnitt eines van damme movies
abkanzelte als dutzend paare ich dachte
eigentlich ganz gut geworden
schreibt fürs fernsehen kenne wirklich
nur in frage um ein schreiben von
romanen zu unterstützen aber im moment
kann ich glücklicherweise meine ganze
energie der belletristik widmen mein
name eines ihrer bücher underground
railroad wurde ja zu solch einer amazon
prime serie wenn ich das richtig sie es
wurde verfilmt haben sie da das
bedürfnis oder vielleicht auch die angst
verspürt damit machen zu wollen
nein ich brannte im sommer 2017 darauf
die nickel bei euch zu beginnen ich
hätte ein jahr pause einlegen müssen mal
einer fernsehserie über ein buch zu
schreiben das ich bereits geschrieben
hatte aber die ganze zeit nur cora cora
ich glaube ich habe mich mit der
nickelpreis richtig entschieden
jetzt waren ja die letzten zwei drei
jahre für sie die wahrscheinlich sehr
reiseintensive jahre gewesen wären ganz
andere jahre es wäre eine art
zurückgeworfen hat auch sich selbst
nicht nur ihrer biografie und ihre
situation sondern einer ganzen stadt ein
freund von mir hat gesagt das ist eine
super situation der als schriftsteller
dafür habe ich 20 jahre trainiert das
ist genau die situation für
schriftsteller diese corona krise haben
sie das auch so empfunden dass diese
zurückgezogen hat etwas wahnsinnig
befreien das hatte
es stimmt schon dass ich irgendwie auf
so etwas vorbereitet war da ich ja eh
schon 95 prozent meiner zeit zu hause
verbracht haben auch war ich geübt darin
das schlimmste zu erwarten als pessimist
bist du auf so etwas vorbereitet
es war tatsächlich eine produktive und
kreative zeit nachdem meine kinder mit
den nötigen elektronischen geräten für
den fernunterricht ausgestattet waren
konnte ich mit dem schreiben beginnen
ich konnte nicht aus dem haus und saß am
pult
die nächte brachten dunkle gedanken
angesichts des wartens auf den impfstoff
dolak im werk sehr vielen toten und der
wahrscheinlichkeit der wiederwahl traums
tagsüber aber kam ich mit der arbeit
bevor
vielleicht war ein weiterer aspekt sie
haben es angesprochen
sie sind sehr gerne alleine sie
kultivieren dieses alleinsein als eine
große qualität es gibt auch diese
dunklen momente der traurigkeit das ist
ja auch etwas was david foster wallace
immer mit bespricht den hang allein zu
sein fiktion als kultivierung von
einsamkeit und die traurigkeit die
teilweise auch depressiven momente die
mit damit notwendig einherzugehen
scheint
ich habe bücher geschrieben als ich sehr
glücklich war und ich habe bücher
geschrieben als ich sehr deprimiert war
nichts davon hilft die wörter auf papier
zu bekommen bleibt schwierig
es ist eine sehr einsame arbeit deshalb
gehe ich auch gerne auf lesereisen und
auf die gefahr hin oder es gesellig
gesehen zu werden es hat etwas magisches
zwei jahre lang an etwas zu arbeiten und
dann kommen die leute nach der arbeit zu
deiner lesung anstatt nach hause zu
gehen und hören dir zu und hoffentlich
mögen sie es
vielleicht triffst du ja auch auf
jemanden der volksseele jahren schon mal
bei einer lesung war und der stellt dann
die frage
ich kenne ich du warst schon mal ja
du hier wir leben beide noch wir haben
es geschafft so läuft das jetzt nach der
panini
ich bin tatsächlich ein einzelgänger und
spiele auf den misanthropen aber es ist
ein toller teil meines berufs mit meinen
büchern unter die menschen zugehen und
leserinnen und leser zu treffen
sie haben sich ja nun für einen menschen
der gerne alleine ist ein besonders
seltsam lebensort ausgesucht nämlich new
york city eine stadt in der man nicht so
oft allein ist und die gerade die
letzten zwei jahre auch
sagen wir mal still gestellt war und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass auf den straßen
von manhattan oder new york viele
menschen du hast du lebst auch noch
schön dich wiederzusehen
wir fahren sie denn die stadt jetzt zwei
jahre nachdem sie ja eine besonders
extreme erfahrung gemacht hat
ich schreibe gerade an einem roman über
new york in den 70er jahren eine
schreckliche zeit in der geschichte der
stadt
nie gab es mehr verbrechen
und dabei stieß ich auf ein buch über
die musikszene in new york love comes to
buildings und fall von wilhelms einem
tollen musikkritiker und
new york sah seine eigene ausprägung von
arango jazz
die künstler gehen zurück an die arbeit
auf der straße bautrupps welche die
stadt wieder aufbauen
die künstler finden selbst in solch
schwierigen zeit neun teams pirazzi
fang auch bei mir anna in meiner eigenen
arbeit letztes jahr wohin bewegt sich
die stadt was finden wir vor wenn wir
unsere türen wieder öffnen ich bin
optimistisch dank der impfung strömen
woche für woche mehr leute zurück auf
die straße das ist großartig
es ist spannend über new york schwierige
zeiten zu lesen über die vertriebenen
ureinwohner die mit waffen in die stadt
ein vielen und ein paar kolonialisten
und brachten die feuer brände das
gelbfieber die aufstände nine eleven wir
bauen die stadt immer wieder neu auf ich
sehe mich als teil dieser erneuerung ein
schöner gedanke
[Musik]
das ist ja fast der zweite rote faden in
ihrem werk wenn ich es richtig sehe es
gibt diese gestalten die aufgrund einer
fiktion eine gewisse resilienz
entwickeln und es gibt new york als
großes liebes und handlungs zentrum
viele bücher spielen new york in
neuestes buch h m staffel spielt auch
new york der 60er jahre jetzt gibt es
arbeit die wahrnehmung new york ist
vermischt es ist fertig mit new york das
wird nicht die hauptstadt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sein und
das wird vielleicht nie wieder so sein
wie es einmal war
20 jahren sprach ich darüber dass sich
die rassenfrage nie ändern wird
wenn wir zukaufen new york bin ich etwas
optimistischer
die stadt symbolisiert für mich die
vitalität des lebens
gebäude stürzten ein und werden wieder
aufgebaut wir werden niedergeschlagen
und stehen wieder auf um zu überleben
die residenz der stadt steht für die
resilienz des menschen
mich ermutigt das aufgeben heißt die
hoffnung verlieren
ihr neuestes buch harlem schaffe das ist
auch eine kriminalgeschichte aus dem
gauner value ich glaube sie spielt auch
im jahren und seit 63
fängt dann an das ist auch das gebiet in
dem ihre eltern groß geworden sind in
gewisser weise auch vielleicht eine
auseinandersetzung mit der erfahrung
ihre eltern aber das ist auch vor allem
die idee eines aufsteigers der ein
aufstiegsversprechen hat aber nicht
genau weiß wie es realisieren sollte
also zweifelt daran ob dieser
amerikanische traum für ihn mit legalen
mitteln überhaupt erreichbar ist
ja das männerbild der hauptfigur ray
cooney wird von seinem kriminellen vater
geprägt er selbst wählt einen anderen
weg und bringt sich selbst als college
und die uni und eröffnet ein geschäft
es geht um sozialen aufstieg darum die
hindernisse zu erkennen welche die
gesellschaft in unseren weg legen und
die inneren ressourcen zu finden die es
braucht um dem rassismus dem
kapitalismus und unseren eigenen
schwächen ein schnäppchen zu schlagen
aber es gibt ja zwei typologien wieder
zum einmal haben sie diese durch wurster
und diejenige daran zerbrechen und hier
haben sie die streber und die trickster
die irgendwie das system nicht nach den
regeln die es vorgibt
bespielen sondern nach anderen regeln
sicher die streber die anwälte und
banker versuchen nach den regeln zu
spielen den gaunern wie korn anderen
ganoven und mehr noch den
immobilienhaien und magnaten widerstrebt
das system gruppe sie wollen ihre
eigenen regeln aufstellen
hier tauchen einige argumente aus den
nickelpreis wieder auf er wird glaubt er
kann die welt mit legalen mitteln
verändern und so erfolg und sozialen
wandel
die andere hauptfigur
hält davon nichts bei ihm geht es nur
darum zu überleben egal nach welchem
recht
wenn man darüber nachdenkt haben ja dann
der kleinkriminelle und der
schriftsteller einiges gemeinsam sie
machen anderen menschen dinge vor
entwerfen einen plot eine ganze
handlungs konstellation um durchzukommen
einzelne schriftsteller sitzen am pult
werden von der muse geküsst und wissen
jeden tag wo es langgeht ich brauche
eine sketch entwerfe einen genauen plan
bevor ich mit dem schreiben beginne die
akuter krimineller sie haben da einen
ganz genauen plan wie das vor sich zu
gehen ja ich habe einen plan ich war es
wo die bank ist und wie ich da rein
komme ich halte mich an die einzelnen
schritte und ziehe es durch ich bin ein
flotter und ein planer ein guter canovi
muss ein guter plotter und planer sein
jetzt gibt es ja eine andere große
leidenschaft die auch mit etwas
vormachen mit fiktion zu tun hat in
ihrem leben nämlich procar ein spiel bei
dem es ja eigentlich nur darum geht
größer zu wirken als man ist oder
zumindest nicht kleiner zu wirken als
man ist
ja und bei meinen recherchen merkte ich
dass pokerspieler äußerst hoffnungsvoll
menschen sind sie glauben fest daran
dass sich mit der nächsten hand im
nächsten straight flush dem nächsten
vierling ihr elendes leben irgendwie
ändern wird die schicksalsgöttin gibt
die die karten die alles zum guten
wenden das entspricht dem traum eines
erfolgreichen gaunerstück wenn du den
plan richtig umsetzt kannst du deinem
elenden schicksal ein schnippchen
schlagen und aufsteigen
es gibt ja zwei typologien von ganoven
erzählungen das gelungene gaunerstück
wie ocean's eleven mit dem
gutaussehenden jungs in den gut
sitzenden anzügen die es locker
durchziehen und das düstere ganoven
steckt eine wirklich gut ist und sich
aber mit verlierertypen und geben muss
der fluchtfahrer spritzt sich dann am
vorabend heroin der safeknacker hat
knapp mit seiner frau und ist
entsprechend neben der spur und die
ganze planung geht im bach weil das
schicksal es so will all die träume
werden zur illusion die sie sind ich
neige eher zur missratenen gaunerstück
in meinem buch
aber es gibt ja schon die parallelen im
leben eines schriftstellers man kann
sagen man geht schriftsteller dasein ich
es findet ein weil man das tun muss aber
wenn man so mit 20 anfängt und sagte ich
bin von meinen büchern leben dann kann
man ja sagen also da setzt du alles auf
den grand slam den nun mal in die hand
bekommst und du wirst ihn wahrscheinlich
nicht in die hand bekommen also man
spielt ja eine art programm mit seiner
eigenen biografie wenn man sich für
diesen weg entscheidet
nun damit sind wir wieder bei der
unterscheidung zwischen den kommerziell
oder den künstlerisch erfolgreichen
büchern
ich habe aufgehört mir zu überlegen was
den leuten gefallen könnte ich weiß es
einfach egal
wie hoffnungsvoll ich bin und wie gut
ich plane ich kann die reaktion der
kritiker und leser schlicht nicht
vorhersehen alles was ich tun kann ist
die bücher zu schreiben die mir gefallen
toni morrison sagte sie schreibt motive
die sie lesen möchte und die es noch
nicht gibt dann muss es also selber tun
ich kenne ja nun auch einige
schriftsteller und ich weiß dass sie das
immer öffentlich erzählen ich weiß aber
auch dass daran vielleicht nur die
50-prozentige wahrheit ist weil es gibt
agenten es gibt die verlage es gibt
menschen in einem umfeld und wann ist es
ja oft so man hat eine idee man erzählt
die idee und der agent macht mir so und
dann geht die idee wieder weg also ist
es denn wirklich so dass man das nur für
sich entscheidet dass das ein innerer
drang so da ist man nicht ständig doch
orientiert in einem feld von menschen
die sagen das lässt jetzt mal lieber
sein und das thema ist besser
es ist nicht so dass ich mir rat hole
aber ich brainstorm neue ideen mit
meiner agentin und dem verleger bei dem
wenig übrigen schon seit 20 jahren was
selten vorkommt
mein erstes buch handelte von einer
afro-amerikanischen fahrstuhl
inspektoren auf diese verrückte reise
sind sie eingestiegen klingt jetzt nicht
nach dem nach dem topseller
ich hatte ja gehofft ich würde auf
dieser modewelle in der popkultur rundum
fahrstuhl inspektoren reiten aber ich
habe es ihm zwei jahre verpasst
es ist so dass ich meinem verleger
erzähle was ich vorhabe er sagt dann
macht das ich bring schon irgendwie raus
etwas besseres kann einem eigentlich
nicht passieren dass jemanden auf seiner
seite zu haben der auch bei der
schrägsten idee mit dabei ist
so eine mischung von night of the living
dead und black hawk down sagte er ich
hasse horrorfilmen habe noch nie an
solchen roman gelesen aber wenn du
schreibst finden wir einen weg es zu
verkaufen genau das möchte man als
schriftsteller jemand der dir sagt mach
dein ding und wenn du damit fertig nicht
schauen wir mal
ich habe jetzt diesen aufzugs roman ich
gelesen aber es ist interessant zu hören
dass sie sagen ihr erst das thema war
ein aufzug weil das ja vielleicht auch
ein grund thema ihres schreibens es geht
man von unten nach oben kommt und welche
mechanismen dafür kennen muss wie man
diesen aufzug in amerika repariert
ja ja ja ich hatte ein buch geschrieben
dass niemand dem gefiel und niemand
veröffentlichen wollen also habe ich
überlegt dass die leute handlungs reiche
bücher mögen
also habe ich die struktur von
kriminalgeschichten untersucht und
gelernt wie man eine geschichte mit
finden wendungen und vorenthaltenen
informationen erzählt dann lief im
fernsehen ein bericht über die
versteckten gefahren für fahrstuhl
inspektoren ich dachte mir was für ein
seltsamer beruf wäre es nicht verrückt
und urkomisch wenn ein fahrstuhl
inspektor gleichzeitig aktiv wäre am
anfang war es reiner zufall
aber wenn man sich gedanken zum thema
aufzüge macht merkt man dass es ohne sie
keine modernen stetig
fahrstühle stehen für die geschichte der
stadt und unsere lebensweise plötzlich
denkt man an den sozialen aufstieg das
konzept des racial abläuft und all diese
metaphern und daraus wurde dann das
merkwürdige kleine buch das es heute ist
fahrstuhl bei ihnen ja relativ weit oben
angekommen im penthouse der literatur so
zu sagen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
viele junge autoren sich auch an sie
wenden und fragen
kursen wie mache ich das denn jetzt wie
werde ich denn jetzt erfolgreich es gibt
von rainer maria rilke diesen
wunderbaren brief an einen jungen
schriftsteller der sagt macht das nur
wenn du es nicht vermeiden kannst
ist das ein tipp den sie aufgeben will
ich bin gelegentlich an autoren
konferenzen wo man nicht manchmal um rat
angeht dann sage ich was tust du
solltest zu hause sein und schreiben was
vergisst du deine zeit mir zuzuhören
setz dich hin und schreibe das ist mein
rat wenn ich etwas anderes tun könnte
würde ich das kann ich aber nicht
schreiben ist mein ding und dann ließ
fiel um herauszufinden welche art
schriftsteller du sein möchtest stößt er
auf ein werk das dir gefällt sie ihre
ess- und finde heraus warum also
schreibe viel um herauszufinden was für
ein schriftsteller du bist das sind wohl
verschiedene dinge wer war denn der
autor dem mit ihnen die verbindung
geschafft hat wo sie sagen dass es das
was ich selber schaffen will das ist
derjenige der mich in die literatur
getragen und gebracht hat
ich sehe mich als achtjähriger am lesen
von marvel comics cross selling mit
installation episoden die mir gefallen
meine mutter jedes jahr den neuen
stephen king kaufte der über meine
geschwister zum ihr fall safari von
coach und dem feuer kennt und überlege
mir wie toll es wäre mir verrückte
geschichten über vampire und werwölfe
auszudenken dank meinen frühen
erfahrungen mit der fantasy literatur
und dem fernsehen reifte der gedanke was
für ein toller job es wäre sie seltsame
dinge auszudenken hätte
in unserem alter hat man als man ja auch
noch träume sie sagten making things up
rotten wenn sie jetzt noch mal ein
kleinst verbrechen planen und begehen
wollten was wäre denn das kleinst
verbrechen das sie am meisten reizen
würde
es gibt ein neues museum in amerika das
american museum auf black history and
culture
die zeigen dort all diese tollen hip hop
objekte wie curtis bloß trainingsanzug
oder
afrika bambaataa plattenspieler
wäre
afrika bambaataa plattenspieler zu
klauen oder
kanu es turnschuhe
aber er ist nicht wirklich mein tipp all
diese objekte der popkultur des punk und
hiphop verstauben dort als
sammlungsstücke im archiv es wäre doch
cool dort einzubrechen und drums gitarre
zu befreien und sie an die eigene wand
zu hängen
das klingt ja fast schon nach einem
neuen roman
für die zeit begnügen uns waren mit
denen und begegnen uns gerne die wir von
ihnen haben an der grund- railroad den
nickelpreis und jetzt als neuestes dem
shuffle vielen dank dass sie für uns so
schöne fiktionale ausweg entwerfen kurs
leitet
wenn sie jetzt so richtig lust bekommen
haben halbe schachtel zu lesen wir
verlosen ein signiertes exemplar auf der
facebook-seite von saf kultur nächste
woche trifft barbara bleisch philippe
petit einen superstar der philosophie
der professuren an den renommiertesten
universitäten hat und ursprünglich mal
priester werden wollte wie und was
dieser philosoph denkt und vor allem
woran er heute unbedingt glaubt nächste
woche erfahren sie es
[Musik]